and we need to find out if this weather
satellite picked up on something flying
through how do you react to that that
astronomers would like nothing more for
these to be real we don't have credible
reports that where it's really credibly
come out and been verified how do you
react to those kinds of assertions all
of these satellites that are doing
thermal imaging watching animal
migrations weather satellites spy
satellites it collects data all day long
and he's like we need to scan that data
and we need to find out if this weather
satellite picked up on something flying
through but these satellites aren't
really geared to pick up things moving
20 000 miles an hour and doing a 90
degree turn but it still might be in
there but we have to do some software to
kind of pull it out but then we have the
videos that come out there's so many
more videos that we know that are
probably classified not so much because
of what's on it but maybe where they
filmed it or how good the resolution is
or whatever those things are but those
things do exist we've filmed these
things the military has them the
government has them on the best systems
that have ever been created in the
history of man